it's been nearly six years since
interstellar christopher nolan sci fi
space epic starring Matthew McConaughey
and Anne Hathaway grace silver screens
worldwide in the half decade plus
falling it's October 2014 debut it seems
everyone is one that whether Nolan would
go back into the depths of space toy
with time and tug on heartstrings with
an interstellar sequel but what are the
chances that will actually happen will
we ever get to see interstellar to sign
away with McConaughey's widowed engineer
and ex NASA pilot Joseph Cooper and
hathaways scientist dr. Amelia brand
that is Center interstellar followed the
crew of the spaceship endurance as it
traveled through a wormhole near Saturn
in order to survey twelve worlds that
humanity could move to abandoning the
increasingly uninhabitable earth the
film grossed nearly 678 million dollars
at the global box office and earned
accolade upon accolade during the
2014-2015 awards season including an
Oscar for Best Visual Effects
well northern hasn't confirmed or denied
that a second interstellar is in the
stars but there's some information
lingering out there that helps us answer
the big question
McConaughey revealed in November of 2014
that he's open to signing on for a
second interstellar movie should the
opportunity arise and if everything
about the project feels right when Sky
News us to him whether viewers would get
to see an interstellar sequel with him
reprising his role McConaughey was open
to the idea oh I don't know I'd have to
dude go through my diligence that I
always go through script director etc
but it's uh it's possible he echoed the
sentiment of IGN that same month I have
no idea it is TV abdel for a possibility
for life to carry on adventures to carry
on McConaughey's comments obviously show
that he's interested in making an
interstellar sequel or at least was as
of November 2014
now McConaughey is down to do a sequel
shows that he truly believes in
interstellar as a prophecy and you know
actor enthusiasm is a pretty big thing
when it comes to getting a follow-up
film going McConaughey's remarks
highlights something very important when
it comes to discussing sequels whether
one would make any sense at all
but conahey noted that a script would
have to be rock-solid in order for him
to join the interstellar sequel meaning
he's not going to
running for the project of the story has
even slightly flimsy and with
interstellar a second movie could very
much be limp uninspired or worse yet
force considering whether film left off
there isn't a lot that know that or any
other writer director for that matter
could do with a sequel sure I could deal
with Cooper's relationship with Amelia
brand and Chronicle their time on dr.
wolf Edmunds planet but is that
something people would be interested in
seeing on the other hand that
interstellar follow-up could be more of
a spin-off movie possibly centered
around Cooper's son Tom or it might go
the prequel sequel route of course the
question of audience interests apply to
these possibilities it appears that the
interstellar fandom is split some like
Reddit user bearcat 27a clamoring for a
second film they wrote in a forum post
high on my hardcore interstellar fanboy
wishlist is a sequel just to tell the
story of Cooper's journey back to brand
and to see what life is like on this new
planet interstellar and like Nolan's of
the film's hints at a story in the
future but leaves the viewer to fill in
the gaps
it just seems cruel to me that a last
scene is sending Cooper on a journey
that will never get to experience others
hope that interstellar - never happens
[Music]
one fan posted on reddit I feel the
sequel would ruin the first film
tremendously as there's one of his
signatures though then tied up
interstellar in the exact way he wanted
to with a happier ending that wasn't all
doom and gloom as the original script he
wrote with Jonathan Nolan was it stands
to reason that's when it comes to
possibly making interstellar - if Nolan
wants to do it he will but right now it
looks like a sequel is nothing more than
hypothetical though no that might end up
surprising us and taking a stab at a
second movie provided he actually has
more to say about humanity love and
space check out one of our newest videos
right here Plus even more looper videos
but your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the pal so you don't miss a single one
[Music]